[Music]
hello and welcome to sophie ridge on
sunday with me jane secker
well it was an evening which began with
silent reflection and ended
in anger and violence hundreds of women
gathered on clapham common to remember
sarah everard to hold her memory dear
and demand
changes that would make all of us feel
safer some of those there had tears in
their eyes
one woman told me that she came with a
broken heart
well the metropolitan police had refused
to give the organizers a permit because
of covert restrictions
as the sun dipped officers pushed their
way onto the bandstand amid boos
and the chance of let her speak instead
of
speaking there were arrests and this
morning an outcry from across the
political spectrum with calls
for the metropolitan police commissioner
cressida dick to resign
well should she today we will put that
to the minister
for safeguarding victoria atkins he'll
be joining us in just a moment
we'll also be hearing from labour's jess
phillips
the victims commissioner dame vera baird
is also
on the show to share her expertise and
we'll be talking about where we go from
here
with diane abbott one of westminster's
most independent
minded mps also the co-founder of the
women's equality party catherine mayer
and the chair of the mayor of london's
violence against women and girls panel
joan smith well last night the gathering
was peaceful
although pretty vocal until the police
pushed their way in to try to bring it
to an
end and it's their behaviour which is
now under scrutiny
in a moment we'll speak to the
safeguarding minister victoria atkins
but first let's
hear from some of the women who attended
last night's vigil
why do you think this case in particular
has really cut through
that people feel so strongly about it
that they're willing to come down
despite the fact they know it's illegal
i think that people can see themselves
in this case um
i've yet to meet a woman who hasn't had
those feelings walking home of being
followed
and clutching your keys a little bit
tighter because you want to be able to
defend yourself should someone jump out
checking over your shoulder when you
unlock the front door um and
you know through to much more serious
things i think
it's important that we also remember
there's like a human being at the center
of this
and i think you know some of that
feeling is grief
[Applause]
this is not the organized vigil these
are people who've just come down
here this evening because they are angry
and also because they are upset
my heart is broken why that's why
because we can't
flip and go outside without having keys
between my
feet and your fingers without telling
everyone where you are
you can't do anything without feeling
unsafe
and i think we need to we need to come
and show our respect to sarah and her
family
we spend our whole lives we we grow up
being taught
to live in fear we don't get taught
to not attack women growing up i can't
talk too elegantly right now i'm just
too emotional
i came because i wanted to pay my
respects to a woman
who reminds us all of ourselves so so
prominently
it's clearly really hard for you but you
still want to come yeah
yeah thankfully we're local to the area
so it's
safe too in a way but yeah it definitely
feels important to be
here we've been thinking about sarah for
the last 10 days and it felt really
important to come
and quietly show our respects really and
that's why we came
i've got two teenagers and i
want them to feel safe on the street and
it felt important actually to
to be outside today that's that's why we
[Applause]
came
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're not leaving the area
a lot of people here are really really
angry they're angry at the police
and they're making that really clear but
a lot of people here are also
incredibly upset a lot of the people
that we spoke to this evening
have tears in their eyes
[Music]
well the safeguarding minister victoria
atkins joins us now thanks very much for
talking to us this morning victoria
um given the seven days we've had it's
international women's week
with public anger great public anger at
the place of women in society
what were the police thinking last night
well first of all can i just reflect on
the fact that this has been
an unimaginable week uh for
the family and friends of sarah everard
the the
loss that they are suffering is beyond
our comprehension
and i think in response to that the
reaction that we've seen
from women across the country in terms
of their own
experiences of sexual harassment in the
street and violence and
being frightened to walk in our streets
is also very very shocking
and very very upsetting and so last
behave the way they did
it through the day we saw many people
come to that particular part of clapham
common to
pay their respects to lay a flower
around the bandstead
and of course the majority of them
had a peaceful experience now the scenes
that we've seen
later on in the day in the evening are
very upsetting
and i i take it very seriously the home
secretary
takes it very seriously which is why she
has asked the metropolitan commissioner
for a report on what has happened last
night
take a look at this image if you're able
to um
it's the image of the young girl who is
on the ground with the police officers
on top of her
is that the state of british policing
today
i i you'll have to forgive me i don't
have a screen here but i
imagine i hope i'm thinking of the right
photograph because i've seen
the photograph both on social media and
of course in newspapers
and and that photograph is something
that the police will have to explain
in their report to the home secretary i
think
any policing of large events is
is difficult at the best of times but
we're in the middle of a pandemic with
all of the
rules that flow from that and of course
last night people were very very upset
there was a great deal of emotion
to completely understandably and
the police being as they are
operationally independent
will be having to explain that to the
home secretary in their report
when you say it's difficult to police in
a pandemic
if we think back to the images that we
saw a week ago
when there were football uh celebrations
in the streets up in glasgow after
rangers win
hundreds and hundreds of men walking
through the streets
essentially just being allowed to by the
police
this was a very small group of women who
were confined
onto a bandstand i was there it was cold
it was dark people were petering away
what was the what was the rationale
behind
going in to stop that
well as i say it is for the police to
make these decisions
often in the moment when they're
policing
major events but i i'm pleased that you
were able to go i
myself chose to take part in the virtual
vigil
we found i hope between us we found many
different ways of marking
our respect and marking our concerns
about the issues that have been raised
this week
but as i say the home secretary has
required
a report from the met commissioner to
look into these and that's right because
the police
have to be operationally independent i
don't think anyone would want
a scenario whereby politicians are
directing the police
but it is also right that they are held
to account
by democratically elected politicians
and that they explain
uh their actions to the wider public and
indeed just today
i've seen that the borough commander has
acknowledged uh on social media that
last night was very difficult they're in
a very difficult place at the moment
and so i do hope that we'll be hearing
uh explanations
uh in the hours and days to come i mean
another report pretty patel says
i mean i can tell you that the woman
there last night didn't want another
report they wanted something done
do you think our police force is sexist
do you think what you saw last night was
sexist policing
well actually if i may just just take
you up on that point about action
we in response to the outpourings
of anger and experiences that we've
heard this week
on friday we reopened
the public survey that has been feeding
into and shaping
our new forthcoming national strategy on
tackling
violence against women and girls this
was this is the largest ever survey
that's ever been conducted to tackle
violence against women and girls
and already by the time of the deadline
we had 15 000
responses from members of the public i'm
really pleased to say that since we
reopened it
at 6 00 p.m on friday we've had a
further 20
000 responses from the public so look if
you want change if you want
your voices to be heard we are listening
and please
please put your views your experiences
into the public survey if you look at
the gov
uk website it's there please tell us
your views and experiences because then
you can help us shape
this strategy that we're creating and
that will be published later this
year but there will be there will be a
lot of there'll be there'll be a lot of
women
saying and saying that these are simply
platitudes you know we're going to talk
to vera bird in a short while the
victim's commissioner
she has put together a number of reports
about failings in the criminal justice
system
in the police service towards women it's
another report isn't it
um priti patel is the home secretary has
she not got any ideas of her own why is
she asking the whole population to come
up with a strategy for her
this is a problem women in society
and the levels of crime that they are
victims to
that we are well aware of we need action
not more research
and in fairness you have seen action
from this government at the moment we
have the domestic abuse bill
going through parliament i have led on
that this is a groundbreaking piece of
legislation
that uh is really changing the way that
victims of domestic abuse are treated
and in addition perpetrators of domestic
abuse are treated
this is real action that will have a
huge impact
on the 2.3 million victims of domestic
abuse
that we know live in this country but
that is in
violence in the home the next step now
is for us is
us looking at violence on the street and
other forms of violence against women
and girls
there is a huge range of different
crimes that disproportionately affect
women and girls from
sexual harassment in the streets through
to fgm forced marriage
and stalking the government is
absolutely working on all of this and
the national strategy
that is being published this year is
because we want to set this
for local commissioners the police
councils etc across the country we want
this to be the the guide if you like um
to tackling these sorts of crimes i
really don't think it's fair
to make those allegations that you're
making i totally understand why
in the spirit and the emotion of the uh
moments
uh this week that the people are
thinking that but believe you me this
comes from the very top the prime
minister
is personally committed to this the home
secretary is and i am
this is a huge piece of work and we want
to listen to members of the public my
goodness
if we weren't listening to members of
the public i think you would rightly be
criticizing us
actually and some of the experiences
that we've heard this week
absolutely must be reflected in our
national strategy going forward
well let's move away from as you say the
spirit and the emotion of the week let's
just look at
brutal facts over the last 11 years of
the conservative government
the rate of rape so this isn't that the
rate this is
the rape of rape charges so this isn't
people going to court being found guilty
or not guilty
it's the percentage of people who
actually get charged by a police officer
with rape it's 1.4 percent that's
happened under the conservative
government
in the last couple of weeks anthony
williams given a five-year sentence for
throttling his wife in lockdown
apparently he just flipped also
uh in the last couple of weeks a man was
spared jail after dragging a woman to
the ground
and molesting her part of his defence in
court was
if he went to jail he would lose his job
these are crimes against women and women
look at what happens when they report
crimes and they say that this government
this police force this justice service
isn't serving
us and we hear we absolutely hear that
and what is more
we want it to change which is why as
part of
uh on top of the work that we're doing
with the domestic abuse bill and the
tackling violence against women girls
strategy we are also conducting
an in-depth review into the criminal
justice system
from end to end when it comes to rape
and sexual assault investigations
there are we it is absolutely in depth i
mean two of the examples you've given
there
the sentence and the well both of the
sentences of course those are matters
for judges the judiciary are independent
of government
but that has not stopped us looking at
their role
in the course of this end-to-end rape
review it is absolutely critical
that uh every single part of the
criminal justice system
plays its role in ensuring that
perpetrators are brought to justice
and by way of uh example only tomorrow
we are bringing forward the police crime
sentencing and courts bill
and one of the most important measures
in that as far as i'm concerned
is that we will be increasing the
minimum sentence
that serious and violent offenders serve
in prison
at the moment they're let out at half
halfway through their sentence
we're increasing that to two-thirds
because we absolutely
understand the public's horror that
violent and sexual offenders should be
let out of jail at an early stage in
their sentence so that is just one
example we're also making
very real change changes to what are
called sexual harm prevention orders
and sexual risk orders these are orders
that can be imposed either when someone
has been convicted
or when uh they if there there hasn't
been a conviction at all in the
case of sexual risk orders these orders
help the police to manage
these sexual offenders and and we're
going to make these orders even tougher
so we're going to require for example
where appropriate that offenders have to
undertake positive requirements as part
of the order so
there's a huge amount of work going on
on this because we absolutely
understand and recognize public concern
about this and we want
to deal with it um
you're the safeguarding minister you
will know these figures but if you're a
police officer accused of domestic
violence you're less likely to be
convicted
compared to the general population
around 3.9 percent of
of police officers are convicted
compared to around 6.2 percent of those
in the general population
i mean some would say that both of sets
of those figures are pretty low
do you think the police as it is at the
moment should be investigating their own
do you think we need changes there
well we have uh we've got a training
programme
called domestic abuse matters which is
being rolled out across police forces
primarily to help them support victims
and investigate some of the most
difficult domestic abuse crimes that
exist so
we we know we long know that people in
the past have tended to think of
domestic abuse as perhaps
physical violence sadly we know it is
not restricted to physical violence and
it can include
coercive controlling behavior and the
many many forms in which that can
be deployed and what we have found is
that as this training has been rolled
out not only have the
conviction rates in those force areas
very much
improved but also that police officers
themselves
have either realized that they
themselves are victims of domestic abuse
or they are worried about their own
behavior
and so i've always said you know the
bill this is a landmark piece of
legislation i mean we
in the bill itself um we are we've
responded to the concerns for example
about
the increase in non-fatal strangulation
we're prohibiting that in this bill
we've responded to the concerns about
threats to use revenge porn we've put
that in the bill
and we have responded to the concerns
about
the so-called rough sex defense these
are all issues that affect women
not just in personal relationships but
in
when they're out on dates and so on and
so what we've wanted with this bill is
to really really start a conversation
about abusive behavior
and what we can do to support victims
but also to tackle perpetrators
and in on the last matter what we're
doing is investing
unprecedented amounts of money now in
perpetrator programs
because we want to stop that cycle of
abuse and so
i think you know we really are at a
turning point when it comes to
the way in which we as a country are
dealing with
crimes that disproportionately affect
women and girls i think this week is a
really significant
moment i think that you know the
experiences of women that have been
expressed
have been absolutely um shocking i think
a lot of
men have not quite realized what their
loved ones their sisters their
girlfriends theirs their wives have gone
through and
i genuinely believe this could be a
moment of change
well a lot of people would welcome that
certainly i mean let's let's
roll back to last night and the scenes
we saw
uh there's been a lot of criticism of
the policing uh also criticism of
cressida dick uh the lib dems calling
for her to go
kierstama saying that the images are
deeply disturbing
i'm just thinking of the met and and
putting the sarah everett case aside
uh in terms of police but you know we
had that case not that long ago with
police taking
selfies of themselves with dead women's
bodies
do you think cressida dick really needs
to go now
well in terms of that incident i mean i
think everyone
was horrified by that including uh the
met commissioner and those officers were
dealt with very quickly
um i i i really really want uh to
support the home secretary in her um
request to have a report for cressida
um the the the police have got a tough
job in policing the coronavirus pandemic
uh more generally at the moment i think
you know we
need to be taking selfies with
themselves should they if you know
they're dealing with a pandemic they're
dealing with all of this
it just doesn't seem that their
priorities are in the right place in the
right place
well i if i may i wouldn't want an
entire
um the entire police force across the
country the 43 peace forces to be tarred
with
those incidents um i i you know the
police officers i've had the pleasure of
working with not just as a
as a minister but in my previous role
prosecuting criminals
um you know that that is not behavior
that is um
that i've ever ever clearly um witnessed
so i i
i just i think this morning given
how difficult last night was after what
has been
an incredibly upsetting week i just i'm
very keen that we
don't preempt the fine you know that
report
uh and that we we give the met
commissioner a chance to
uh explain what happened last night you
think she should explain
you think there is a potential that she
may go
so the home secretary has asked for a
report so
and i think that's appropriate you know
the police are operationally independent
but it's right that
they explain their their actions to the
home secretary particularly
in the very very um difficult
circumstances of this week so
um you know i think we've got to take
this step by step this morning
and again i'm just very conscious that
for the family and friends
of sarah everard this is this is not
what anyone
wanted and certainly if people who took
part in the virtual vigil
people who were there in peace people
who were laying their flowers
this is this is not what any of us
wanted and and i i very much hope that
we will be talking about the
um much more positive steps that we can
and will be taking
to tackle violence against women and
girls through the government survey
and other work victoria atkins we
appreciate you coming on this morning
thank you
well unless we forget international
international women's day was this week
well since she was elected in 2015
labour's jess phillips has marked the
occasion
by reading out the names of the women
and girls killed in the uk
where a man has been charged or
convicted this year
there were 118 names in this place we
count what we care about we count the
vaccines done we count the number of
people on benefits
we we rule or oppose based on account
and we obsessively track that data
we love to count data about our own
popularity
however we don't currently count dead
women
no government study is done into the
patterns every year are the data of
victims of domestic abuse who are killed
die by suicide or die suddenly dead
women is a thing we've all just
accepted as part of our daily lives dead
women is just one of those things
killed women are not banishingly rare
killed women
are common
well we're going to be talking to jess
phillips in just a moment before we do
let's just remind ourselves
of some of the footage uh that was from
last night this was the
peaceful vigil that was held around the
band stand at six o'clock
last night in clapham common this was
not an organized vigil the reclaim the
streets had tried
uh to organize a covert safe vigil they
weren't able to reach an agreement with
the
metropolitan
police so it was cancelled and instead
it was carried out virtually online at 9
30 but there were many people in clapham
who just felt that they really
wanted to come down last night whether
it was
allowed or not and there was a an even
smaller group of women who were
certainly
more vocal and more angry they were on
the bandstand
and they very much made their feelings
known
and then as we know we've seen those
images as the police came in to try to
move them on
well let's talk to labour's shadow
domestic violence
minister jess phillips joins us now
thanks a lot for joining us this morning
you may have heard we talked to victoria
atkins there um she's saying what we
need now is
a report from the police and they want
uh women and men from across the country
to also
write to the government on their survey
to say what they think
should be done to improve the lives of
women and girls in the uk
is that okay is that enough absolutely
not enough
um oh gosh uh doing another review
whilst i think it's important that the
public at this moment of public
outpouring feel that they have an avenue
for that
and the government survey is one way
that people can come forward and say
what they think
but the issue of street harassment the
issue of sexual violence the issue of
domestic violence and all violence
against women and girls
we know what the problems are the home
secretary has known
for many years the minister has known
for many years
and it's it's just the reality is is
that last year 24
fewer rape convictions occurred domestic
homicide is at
an all-time high these we don't need a
survey
we can take action we can have policy
both through the domestic abuse bill
and also through the bill that is coming
before parliament on monday
we can change laws that mean that people
actually get good
sentences for rape that are sentenced at
all
that street harassment could be a crime
because it's not illegal to
harass women on the street currently we
don't need
a review we need action
how how far how much of the problem do
you think
is the police i mean as someone who was
there last night it did feel that the
police
slightly misread the move the mood and
you know they've also
advised people in the area women in the
area not to go out alone and there was a
lot of anger there last night about that
a lot of people there felt that it
encouraged
a victim-blaming culture do you think
the police are guilty of this
look the mistake if we're talking about
the vigil specifically or that the
police
generally need to be doing more in cases
of violence against women and girls
i'm afraid to say that that both are
true um
yesterday there were oh gosh so many
missed opportunities throughout the day
for the police to work with organizers
to create a completely safe vigil
so that people could go and have a
moment
of sorrow and a moment of resistance
against
what is the experience of pretty much
all women in the united kingdom and
around the world
and they missed the opportunity at every
every turn
until what we saw was
you know a five foot two tall woman
being pinned down with two
men on her back now what i have done
over many many years working with the
police
there are brilliant police officers in
the west midlands and across the country
who spend all their time trying to make
it
so that women feel confident to come
forward and yesterday
the police undermined that women already
feel like they won't be believed if they
come forward
and the images on the front of every
newspaper today
the police should apologize to the
coppers in my area who
desperately want to help victims of
violence against women and girls
because the police reputation
in this area needs improvement
before we show images of angry men
on the backs of women do you think
crested edict should go
oh gosh i really don't want to write the
headlines so that the headline out of
this is
the labour party calls for crested
dictago before the vigil has even
happened
yesterday i was coming here to talk
about
what needs to change in this one moment
we have
it seems where the politics and the
views and wind is at our back as women
who have been fighting for better
for generations and i'm here talking
about cressida dick
the reality is is that i wish that i'd
had the heavy hand of the law when i'd
been sexually assaulted
i wish for every woman i've ever worked
with that the heavy hand of the law had
been there for them i wish for the woman
in my constituency this week who was
told no further action
on the rape that she'd brought forward i
wish the heavy hand of the place had
been there
for her but the reality is is if crested
dick stays or goes doesn't make women in
this country
more safe and that's what i want to talk
about we need to come together
to take action we don't need to just be
angry we need
action and the minister should be able
to lay out to us
exactly what they're going to do the
labor party has come up with
endless suggestions throughout the
domestic abuse bill some
you know 37 amendments we put down that
would make people
safer and on monday we will again be
asking the government
to look at things like misogyny as a
hate crime street harassment
as a crime and increasing the tariffs
on rape i'm afraid to say the builder is
before us
on monday they're in the explanatory
notes which i read on monday
there is more mentions of statues than
there is of women
10 years for
doing something to a statute what about
women
as you say let's go back to what we did
originally want you to come here
and talk about and it was international
women's day the the names of the 118
women that
you read out in the comments what struck
me
as a news presenter was that there was
no more than a handful of those names
that i recognized dead women don't make
the news these days do they
um why do you think that is but also why
do you think
the sarah everett case cut through that
and has gained so much attention
the sarah rivera case unfortunately
um is is not vanishingly rare when we're
talking about women
killed women being killed happens every
three days in this country and like you
say
most people don't know the names of
those women which is why i read them out
and the sarah rivera case i think cuts
through
because it speaks to the every woman
experience of feeling unafraid
and because we heard the reports of what
she had been doing
prior to going missing the phone call to
the boyfriend the walking
on a busy road it spoke to an experience
that every single woman
in fact the future queen of our country
can even say that it spoke to an
experience that she had felt
and that has ignited something in the
public
that has meant that sarah reverad quite
rightly becomes
a lightning rod a pinnacle for us to get
behind
and that's it's not to say that she
matters more than those other women
who had died she's one of them and
it's on us to respect her family and
to respect all the women who feel
frightened to
take this time and make sure that we say
this is
enough is enough what are we going to do
tomorrow to make sure that this doesn't
happen again
but but being snatched on the street i
mean it's a dreadful situation what has
happened here but that isn't the real
risk
for most women is it that's it is very
much in the minority that this is how
uh women are attacked most of them are
attacked at home
at their partner's home or by their
partner the budget did allocate an extra
19 million pounds for domestic abuse
um in england and wales um
i mean will that help will that make a
difference
well the 19 million pound allocated in
the budget was largely uh to go into
perpetrator services which is absolutely
something that
we should be uh looking at only four
million of it was for
directly for victims and as victoria
ratkin said this morning that's
2.3 million victims in the country so um
50 uh each from this year's budget
you know obviously we always need to do
more um
[Music]
where it should be going though you know
we both have two sons but both of us
we don't want our sons to grow up to be
the kind of men
that behave in this way to women so it
is the men that need to be educated so
shouldn't that be
where the funding goes when we look to
the future and how we can change society
i mean absolutely we should be investing
in perpetrators and
you know the the reality is is that the
government don't have a
currently have a strategy for
perpetrators of domestic abuse which
we've asked for repeatedly there isn't a
government strategy for how to deal with
perpetrators
let's maybe hope that this case has made
them change their minds on that i very
much hope so
but you're absolutely right that this is
about education and we made
uh the the law a number of years ago
that compulsory
healthy sex and relationship education
had to be going on in
in schools that hasn't been started to
be rolled out properly because of the
pandemic which is totally understandable
but the government now have a
responsibility to be setting standards
of what
that education has to be and making sure
that they are resourcing it properly
because we've seen some terrible
examples for example of some schools
where they're teaching girls that boys
are the ones who should instigate
sex so we've got to get this right in
education we've got to get this right in
health we've got to get this right in
welfare we've got to get this right in
housing and we've got to get this right
in criminal justice because in every
single
metric we are failing and in every
single metric women are getting
less safe year on year if you look at
the data
for convictions and you look at the
number of women coming forward
i mean it has been a a terrible week a
lot of women will say and we look at the
sarah everard case and we look at what
happened last night
do you think as victoria atkins said
that maybe this is a turning point maybe
this is something that that a lot of
people have known was a problem within
society but it hasn't really
found a face found a voice and that now
we are at that point
real change may occur
look i really hope so somebody who has
been planning this verro
for my entire career not just my entire
political career i really
i really really really hope that this is
the turning point
but i hope that about me too and not a
single piece of legislation has changed
in the united kingdom
that would protect people from being
sexually harassed at work that didn't
already exist
and every recommendation that has been
made to the government
on women's safety in the workplace since
the metoo movement which we all thought
was a moment
has been rejected by the government out
of hand
so when the minister says this is a
turning point when priti patel says this
is a turning point when boris johnson
says this is a turning point they have
an enormous majority in the house of
commons
they can turn their rhetoric into action
and i want that to be the thing i don't
want platitudes i don't want nice words
i don't want clapping
i don't even want candles i want action
to change this because i am tired of
reading out so many people's names
jess phillips thanks a lot for joining
us this morning
well let's talk more about this with the
victims commissioner dame
vera baird she joins us now and she has
of course carried out a great
amount of research over the years into
uh what is
happening in our criminal justices and
what's happening in the police service
denver when when you saw the footage
last night
from clapham common what wasn't through
your mind well i'm afraid i thought it
made a
bad situation worse and i i didn't
understand it and it will be good when
there is a report to the home secretary
i'm glad
she's called for it my reading last
night showed that something similar
the same sequence happened in the west
midlands i don't know if jess phillips
mentioned this but there was
that same cancellation because the court
wouldn't intervene
and the police said it can't happen
but as in london people went
there were there for an hour they had a
quiet
vigil they went away again and the
police were nowhere to be seen
and you know truly the organizers tried
to cancel the club and common one
they failed completely because obviously
emotions are
pouring over the top now
and and when it happens you know with
what looked like you were there i i
wasn't but it looked like thousands of
people
you know there is no real prospect of
intervening
in it successfully this quasi-military
thing
of circling around the bandstand where
everybody's just
paid good money out of their wages to
put a bunch of flowers down and express
their view
have you knew some large clawed feet on
it
to push people away it seems to me to be
a dreadful
piece of misjudgment are they really
improving
their chances of kobe not spreading by
putting their knees in the middle of the
back of young women
and putting their hands in handcuffs uh
it didn't seem to me to be the right
thing to do
the reclaim the streets marches of
course and this obviously wasn't an
official one
um date back to the 1970s
when you look back at those dates i
think we've even got a
some footage of a picture of of one of
those back
back then in those days do you think
anything has has really
changed are women more or less likely to
be victims of domestic violence now more
or less likely to be victims of rape and
murder
i i think things have got have got worse
you were right to go back to the 1970s
to make the point
of this see this whole series of issues
victim blaming reclaim the night was
about the yorkshire ripper
when the police in yorkshire who
couldn't catch him for many years
told women to stay off the street
women's response to that was he's a man
take men off the street if you want to
keep people safe
do not blame us and and here we are
again it seems the local police were
telling people women not to go
around clapping common because of the
dangers there when the reverse is the
case it isn't about
women's safety it's about men's violence
we had calls this week for uh sorry to
cut across we had calls this week for
for a male
curfew uh that was met by you know a
certain amount of hilarity from some
quarters
but i mean you know in all seriousness
is that something that
should be considered i i think that
there's been an arrest in connection
with this
and curfew is not the point about
um the kind of events of
uh predatory male behavior you know
abusing women on the street
grabbing hold of them flashing them a
curfew isn't going to stop that
what needs to happen is a huge culture
change
and i have to say you know if women's
voices
could change this behavior it would have
stopped a very long time ago
we need real leadership and we need
men to speak out against men of this
nature
who if they don't get discouraged take
another liberty after another liberty
shout at a woman this time
nobody stops you so um go
go to her and tell her why she's why why
are you not taking any notes of me i
just shouted at you
stand in her way the the barriers are
pushed if it's not stop isn't the
real reflection of all the women who've
spoken out and they were you know from
trade unionists to students to
journalists
people in your kind of position jane or
saying they've been harassed in this way
that so far as women are concerned men's
the streets are lawless men can do and
say
what they wish to women on the street
with no sense of a deterrent
through fear of the criminal justice
system and no sense for these women
that they will be protected in the
criminal justice system if they make a
complaint
and and look i don't want to go close to
into sarah everard's case at all she's
tragic and one's heart goes absolutely
out
to her family but you know such notice
did the police take according to the
press
of an allegation that this man had
flashed it to no doubt
worried women in a fast food takeaway a
few days before
they were so ready to investigate who
that was that they were given
a cctv picture with the
license plate of the culprit on it
i should say we need to be so careful
because there is an active court case
and we we wouldn't want to certainly
jeopardize that court case and that may
well
be part of the evidence in that case but
um
you talked about the fact that that
action needs to be taken
is the home secretary up to the job do
you think
oh it's not for me to tell the prime
minister who to appoint to his
cabinet the real point is that there
there is no doubt that the
government has been quite responsive
over the domestic abuse bill
but it simply doesn't go far enough and
the end-to-end rate preview frankly few
people have any
real expectations of it throughout the
time that it's been running i mean the
cps just
stopped prosecuting rape in significant
numbers five years ago and despite
women complaining despite a court case
despite the end-to-end rape review they
have done nothing to reverse that it
still is 1.4 as you have already
said to yourself so there needs to be
some significant
government leadership and there needs to
be a significant
drive to change the culture to
acknowledge that we are in real danger
of losing confidence in the criminal
justice system
from half of the population of this
country
you say it needs leadership it it it
does therefore suggest that you don't
especially have confidence in the
leadership that's currently being
offered
it's about how active that leadership is
isn't it and how much it
sees what is happening and how much it
drives
that agenda i suspect that that people
have
been in leadership have been taken by
surprise
by the outpouring indeed the uproar
that there's been from every kind of
woman in the last
few days the question is now is this a
turning point well
they can make it a turning point that's
the question
is there the political will to tackle
the very serious trouble that the
criminal justice system is currently in
not prosecuting cases against
women so that it really doesn't seem to
women to be worth them
complaining let's just be really clear
increasing sentences for sexual offences
but very very few people are prosecuted
for sexual offences so that's
not going to make the slightest
difference the new legislation
has some possibilities in it but it also
contains
a clause which licenses the police to
take mobile phones
off women with very little control
over that and off every kind of
complainant
this is a retrograde step now the
trouble that there has been
about the cps finding their own demands
for digital download have been
intrusive and irrational and a piece of
legislation coming forward
will legitimize that kind of behavior so
we are in a very mixed picture
where nobody seems to grab this issue
and in a thorough going way go step by
step
through it and say this is the problem
let's
make an answer and can i say they do not
listen to victims
i struggle all the time i have no
statutory power it is my
voice it is the alliances that i can
make
that i can use to try to bring change
but the gap
between the criminal justice system over
here
and the experience of victims
particularly women
over here is amazingly large
and they need to do far far more than
just
not in the direction of consulting by
having the odd meeting with people they
need to be
open and ready to realize the experience
and to be determined to put it right you
say that
women's voices aren't being listened to
you know we've had two female prime
ministers jackie smith was the first
home secretary
of female home secretary back in 2007
but the queen is head of state
um female leadership it seems does not
necessarily affect change in this arena
why do you think that is well one
suspicion is that it's
it's it's still overwhelmingly a
male-dominated culture i mean we
obviously have enormous gender
inequality still
in the economies uh in in jobs uh in
representation at high levels of course
things have gone a little bit better
but overwhelmingly the culture that
dominates is male
it is male priorities that go forward
and some women struggling to try to be
heard like jess
um and you know arguably like some of
the government ministers who are women
don't don't pick up you know a
forward moving culture that is
keen to help it is blocked at every
level by the fact that men don't have
these experiences so it's not a priority
for men a really telling thing you know
when i was a member of parliament a long
time ago
we discussed domestic homicide in
parliament and it had never been top of
any male mp's
agenda as soon as it was really
explained what was going on
men started to take an interest but
that was a time of progress
you have to be constantly stepping and
stepping and pushing and pushing
to regress ins to redress institutional
inequalities and if you stop doing that
so for instance
just cut down the number of rape cases
you prosecute so that you
look as if you're getting a better
conviction rate for the ones you take
then the whole thing just settles
backwards
into the same old male dominated
prejudices
progress stops so easily we just need to
keep going and the government does have
to
lead this okay vera bad victims
commissioner
good to talk to you thanks a lot for
joining us
well let's broaden out a little bit and
discuss where we go
from here i'm joined by three women one
of westminster's most
independent minded mps diane abbott
also the co-founder of the women's
equality party
catherine mayer and as well the co-chair
of the mayor of london's violence
against women and girls panel joan smith
uh thank you all so much f for joining
us this morning
um ask you all the same question first
and then we'll move on um
cressida dick is it time for her to go
diane abbott
we would hope that if she goes
that she's actually replaced with
somebody better
someone that doesn't deny institutional
racism exists in the police force
and someone with a much less
heavy-handed
approach to public order issues
catherine
uh i think that her position is
untenable but the danger
of just seeing her resign is that this
will then become
a problem about her leadership as
opposed to being something systemic
as opposed to being something that is
not just a failure
of policing and the police culture but
also of politics
and i'm really quite worried that rather
like the way the metoo movement sort of
unleashed all of these testimonies
but then kind of drew back from
the kind of systemic change we needed
that we're at exactly a kind of
moment where the same thing could happen
we we can make in
we can make progress now people see what
the problem is
but they will be very easily distracted
and in a horrible way
this um churn with
cressida at the top of the police
this discussion the discussion of what
happened last night
it's all very important but it mustn't
distract from the bigger issue okay
and joan very briefly do you think we we
should
be asking if she should go do you think
she should go
my personal view is that she's
mishandled this right from the start
right going back to wednesday when i
i was really taken aback by the
statement she put out when
when metropolitan police announced
they'd found human remains and i think
she's got the tone wrong from the start
and i agree that you know her going is
actually not
the most important thing at the moment
but i do think there's a serious
question about leadership at the
metropolitan police
okay dan let's go back to you um a lot
of women
have been sharing their experiences this
week of harassment on the street
of sexism in the workplace you shared
your experiences
you've talked about uh hearing a man's
footsteps and crossing the road as a
habit of a lifetime
have things got better do you think from
from those days when you first got
elected into parliament back in 1987
um just on the creta de dick question i
think it's important to remember that
the local
police in lamberth wanted the peaceful
vigil to go ahead or willing to work
with you
it was crested a dick and people at
scotland yard
that insisted on banning it all together
but everybody knew people would turn up
anyway
so she does have questions to answer in
relation to experience inheritance on
the street
i think in some ways it's got worse
because what you've got
is the online world which feeds
um hostility and
violence against women um and
i was struck when i started to think
about it how much i had always taken it
for granted that the potential for
violence by men
on the street was just something that
you
you had to guard against by crossing the
road
catherine do you think there is a link
through all of this
with with what you were trying to do
with women's equality party
fighting for equality uh equal pay equal
representation
this low level of misogyny do you think
that that is the root of the problem
that that then feeds into
the broader picture absolutely i mean
one of the things we've been seeing in
pandemic the ways in which inequalities
of all kinds are laid bare the people
who were already vulnerable have been
made more vulnerable it has
been gendered in its impacts it has
hit people of color harder it has hit
people with disabilities in different
and harder ways
and what you see play out now
with with this and with this whole
discussion in fact
is um as as what we're all trying to
talk about
is the endemic nature of this
and the fact that it has not been
tackled it is never tackled it always
um you know you'll see tinkering about
the edges
but it isn't treated like terrorism
or as a form of terrorism as something
that is absolutely
central and that is linked to all these
different sort of
cultural strains to an education system
two forms of inequality
that feed back into this and amplify it
and so
what you need to do is in a moment like
this where you can see those mechanisms
you need to lay them bare and you need
to look for
leadership but you know in the political
sphere
i keep saying that there are these
excellent women like diane who have been
working for years trying to push this up
the agenda and yet it doesn't happen
and yet here we are at our age seeing it
in many ways as diane said getting worse
not better
so this is a question about priority
this is a question about understanding
the ways in which all of those different
inequalities make this
not just tragic but tragically
inevitable
and you know this is this is preventable
but it is only preventable
if it is made a national priority if
um men step up to the plate if male
politicians recognize this and if there
is a
wider um a conversation
about and not just a conversation i mean
we have a a whole load of very specific
policy proposals on this um
including indeed making it
a national priority um
on on the you know um it should be
identified as a national threat
violence against women okay like jess
spring and joan i mean i mean joan you
you know you've talked about living in a
society where some
humans are worth less than others do you
think
um as catherine alluded to that possibly
we have hit a turning point possibly
something very good could come of this
very very difficult week
well i very much like to think so but at
the same time
i feel a kind of disconnect between what
people
say on occasions like this when they're
horrified by
what's happened to a particular woman
which is absolutely horrendous and i
think
you know we all feel very distressed
about it but some of these people who
are expressing you know
shock and outrage now are the same
people who will carelessly read about a
rape trial
in the newspaper and say god you know
why was she on her own at night why did
she go to that man's hotel room
so i think there's a kind of you know
this is there's always these moments
where it feels as if things are going to
change but what we've actually got
is a broken justice system and that
reflects
the misogyny of the culture that we
inhabit
so for years now we've been having we've
had so many rape reviews i could
probably paper the walls of my house
with their findings
it doesn't change anything the you know
the conviction rate keeps going down and
that is because of suspicion and
disbelief towards women
that it's very easy to say gosh what
happened to this woman was particularly
awful
but actually what's happening to
thousands millions of women is awful
but we don't believe them when they tell
their stories and politicians
actually you know there may be a bit of
you know at the moment politicians
saying yes this is actually this is
dreadful
but where are the national campaigns
where are politics where are
candidates mps councillors getting up
and saying
this is this is terrible this is enough
this has got to stop we have to change
the culture
right from the start i mean that's a
that's a good point isn't it diana
abbott i mean
we look at at the government anyway
you know we're half of the country but
we're only a fifth of those who are in
the cabinet
only 34 percent of the house of commons
24 to the conservative party
um westminster's been labeled pest
minster in the past because of issues
uh there with sexual harassment i mean
are we wrong to look to politicians to
change this you know should we be
looking
somewhere else oh in the end
when you want to see substantive change
in a society
the political process is part of that
and to be fair some of us as women mps
have spoken out about these things
but in the past it hasn't necessarily
been seen as news by the media
we need a change in culture we need the
media to take these things seriously not
when there is one dramatic case
but the steady reality
of violence against women but yes at the
end of the day
this needs legislation this needs
funding and this needs
political action and catherine briefly a
lot of men
this week have been questioning what
they can do to make women
feel safer you know i was chatting to my
husband about it and he said well i
always cross the road if i'm
on my own on the street and there's a
woman because it's just something i was
taught when i was younger but
a lot of men don't do that do you think
that possibly we will see a change in
society
from men understanding now what women
silently go through in their head
well diane's point about the media is
very important here it's great that
you're doing a whole program on it but
it needs to be the whole media
talking about this all the time and in
ways that
really make people understand and make
men understand that this is
their issue so it isn't just about
making women feel safer on the street in
those small ways
it's about understanding this as a daily
experience
for women that disfigures the whole of
society
you know that whole kind of thing about
not women trending again
and you know the point is it may not be
all men
who commit violence but it is all women
and it is
all men for whom this is an issue too i
mean one of the most bizarre things is
seeing people seeking
to minimize the experience of women by
saying that more men are
murdered than women yes by men 96
of murderers are men it is a problem for
men and it needs to be seen as one
that is for men to step up to the plate
and solve
so the awareness that you're talking
about is really important but it goes
way beyond this
this is a time for men to actually
understand
that it is in everybody's interest for
them to tackle the problem of male
violence
and joan just last thought from you you
referred to all the different reports
that have been carried out
uh into violence and how you could have
wallpapered your home with them
suzanne moore funnily enough this week
said that misogyny is the wallpaper
that we live with do you have any real
hope that that society
will change only if we can keep this
going and if men ask themselves
questions like
it's not just what do i do if i'm
walking down a dark street and i don't
want to frighten a woman
it's also what happens when your friend
makes a really nasty rape joke
or says something demeaning about women
that nobody else overhears
do you act on that um i think you know
men have to look at their own private
behavior as well and ask themselves
you know are they tolerating a degree of
misogyny which i'm afraid i've been
writing about them for most of my adult
life and you know it's disappointing
that
that we are still here but i do think
it's up to men to look at their own
attitudes the attitudes of their friends
and family
as well as you know talking about what
happens in public
joan smith catherine mayer and diana but
thank you all very much
for joining us for this special program
well that is it for this week uh stay
with us though after this short break
we're going to be discussing a bit more
what we've heard in the programme
on the take over the next half hour
[Music]
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
podcast
but wherever you are welcome to the
safety rage what's the day podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news story
cast
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free
so
so
so
hello and welcome to sophie ridge the
take we'll take a look through the
highlights from today's program and
analyze them with sky's political
correspondent kate
mccann well following the disappearance
and death of sarah everard this week
it's been marked by an emotional
outpouring and a lot of discussions
over women's safety and after police
forcefully broke up a vigil in sarah's
memory last night
there are calls for the met commissioner
to quit and it's those issues
to which we dedicated today's show and
among my guests this morning were the
minister
for safeguarding victoria atkins
labour's jess phillips and the victims
commissioner
dame vera baird well first let's take a
quick look back at my interview with the
safeguarding minister victoria atkins
she refused to be drawn on whether dame
crested dick the chief commissioner
of the metropolitan police should resign
over last night's handling of the vigil
for sarah everett in clapham common
in south london last night
given how difficult last night was after
what has been
an incredibly upsetting week i just i'm
very keen that we
don't preempt the fine you know that
report
and that we we give the met commissioner
a chance to
uh explain what happened last night you
think she should explain
you think there is a potential that she
may go
so the home secretary has asked for a
report so
and i think that's appropriate you know
the police are operationally independent
but it's right that
they explain their their actions to the
home secretary particularly
in the very very um difficult
circumstances of this week so um
you know i think we've got to take this
step by step
well let's cross now to our political
correspondent kate mccann
there has been really widespread
criticism of cressida this morning
from a lot of sectors but again a lot of
people saying
you know is her going the answer would
it actually change anything
yeah i thought it was really interesting
that that was reflected actually quite
strongly throughout the program today
that while there is real fury and
frustration at the way that this
vigil remember it was a vigil it wasn't
a protest it wasn't a march
it was a vigil the way that that was
policed last night i think there is also
a sense that there is a much
broader problem here which requires a
really big
change not just the loss potentially of
crescendo dick she's under a huge amount
of political pressure as you said
the met has already issued a statement
today and said that they felt that there
was a need to intervene
because of the concerns about kovid 19
but i think that's a very difficult line
to hold when you see
actually how some other big events
recently have been
policed including football events and
those are the kind of comparisons really
that the met police are going to have to
try and justify
against when it comes to their actions
but i think when you take a step back
and we're going to get to
clearly jess phillips's interview with
you which i think is really striking
later in the programme this is something
that requires systemic
change it's not just about trying to
lose one
senior person it's about the government
looking at it and making policy and
listening to women now clearly they've
already taken a step towards that
they've kept that consultation open
20 000 responses since sarah everard's
death but
it's going to take more than that i
think i mean the government
you know put pointing to that
consultation and saying you know that
there is the
domestic violence abuse bill which is
going through
the house as well so you know they say
they are taking action
um is the criticism that they aren't
doing enough fair do you think
well certainly some campaigners in fact
many campaigners would say
that it is fair because it's been well
known for
years now that for example rape
convictions
prosecutions for rape are not very good
when compared to other crimes that's not
a secret it's not something new this is
a long-term
problem that the government has been
made aware of repeatedly
and unfortunately the changes that have
been made so far haven't made a
difference so there are questions about
whether the action that's being taken is
enough and
of course there is a bill coming before
parliament early next week where all
kinds of issues like these including
protests will be discussed and i think
the question will be for government
how do they make policy which fits the
public mood but also
is long term because short-term policy
making often
isn't very good there are some really
big fundamental questions about behavior
and a lot of those things
are linked again as jess phillips
pointed out to education to talking to
children in schools about the
appropriate way to behave
and actually about a cultural change too
and a shift that's going to require more
than a policy
to make something happen so i mean it's
a huge issue the government is facing
many of them at the moment but there is
such a groundswell and such a feeling
that now really is that moment that i
think it's going to be really difficult
for them to ignore
um i also kate asked victoria atkins
about whether the rates of charges and
convictions as well as
the strength of sentences are currently
acting as a sufficient
deterrent against crimes for women these
are the facts that i put to the minister
let's just look at brutal facts over the
last 11 years of the conservative
government
the rate of rape so this isn't that the
rate this is
the rape of rape charges so this isn't
people going to court being found guilty
or not guilty
it's the percentage of people who
actually get charged by a police officer
with rape it's 1.4
that's happened under the conservative
government in the last couple of weeks
anthony williams given a five-year
sentence for throttling his wife in
lockdown
apparently he just flipped also
in the last couple of weeks a man was
spared jail after dragging a woman to
the ground and molesting her
part of his defense in court was if he
went to jail he would lose his job
these are crimes against women and women
look at what happens when they report
crimes and they say that this government
this police force this justice service
isn't serving
us and we hear we absolutely hear that
and what is more
we want it to change which is why as
part of
uh on top of the work that we're doing
with the domestic abuse bill and the
tackling violence against women girls
strategy we are also conducting
an in-depth review into the criminal
justice system
from end to end when it comes to rape
and sexual assault investigations
there are we it is absolutely in depth i
mean two of the examples you've given
there
the uh sentence and the um or both of
the sentences of course those are
matters
for judges the judiciary are independent
of government
but that has not stopped us looking at
their role
in the course of this end-to-end rate
review it is absolutely critical
that uh every single part of the
criminal justice system
plays its role in ensuring that
perpetrators are brought to justice
and by way of uh example only tomorrow
we are bringing forward the police crime
sentencing and courts bill
and one of the most important measures
in that as far as i'm concerned
is that we will be increasing the
minimum sentence
that serious and violent offenders serve
in prison
but if you're a police officer accused
of domestic violence you're less likely
to be convicted
compared to the general population
around 3.9 percent of police officers
are convicted compared to around
6.2 percent of those in the general
population i mean some would say that
both of sets of those figures are pretty
low
do you think the police as it is at the
moment should be investigating their own
do you think we need changes there
well we have a we've got a training
programme
called domestic abuse matters which is
being rolled out across police forces
primarily to help them support victims
and
investigate some of the most difficult
domestic abuse crimes that exist so
we we know we long know that people in
the past have tended to think of
domestic abuse
as perhaps physical violence sadly we
know it is not
restricted to physical violence and it
can include coercive controlling
behavior and the many many forms in
which that can
be deployed and what we have found is
that as this training has been rolled
out not only
have the conviction rates in those force
areas
very much improved but also that police
officers themselves
have either realized that they
themselves are victims of domestic abuse
or they are worried about their own
behavior
and kate it was interesting last night
down at clapham that
there was a lot of women there who were
angry about sarah everard they were
angry about
women's place in society but there were
a lot of women there who were very
specifically angry
at the police the government has a job
to do in terms of rehabilitation here
doesn't it to get to get women to trust
the police force
well i don't just think it's about the
police although of course there is that
element to
this it's a much bigger issue of trust
and it's something
that we've heard repeatedly over the
last couple of months
it's not just since sarah everard's of
course tragic death
this has been an ongoing issue lots of
people campaigning for example
about domestic abuse domestic violence
have been saying to the government look
you're not
funding local authorities well enough to
be able to provide
the support that's needed there are
charities who are saying
we cannot give the help that's required
because there isn't enough money for it
there is a huge issue of trust but
there's also an issue of people
saying you know there is a problem here
that needs solving it won't just be
solved by legislation
some of it is about more funding but
some of it is about listening to those
people listening to those voices and
hearing what they are saying
and that does go into what you're
talking about i think about those women
that you spoke to last night
at clapham there is that sense actually
that this issue has been going on for
such a long time
and it has been unsolved even though you
know as victoria ratkins said that there
have been some steps forward
particularly
when it comes to domestic abuse and
domestic violence legislation around
that and around coercive control that's
been really positive
but campaigners have been saying for a
long time that more needs to be done
and it can't be solved overnight but it
has to be a long-term commitment i was
interested actually victoria atkins said
that this is something that the prime
minister is personally committed to
it will be fascinating and actually
really important to see how johnson
responds to what's happened over the
weekend
not just those events that happened on
clapham common but much broader than
that his approach to policy for women
and keeping women safe that's going to
be fundamental i think in the next
couple of weeks and months
well it's interesting because he doesn't
have a huge number of women in his
cabinet does he
know and again that that's something
that's come up repeatedly hasn't it and
there's been some questions about why
for example at those coronavirus press
conferences do we not see more
female cabinet ministers well the answer
often to that is that they they don't
they're not there they're not in those
positions of power and of course
you know boris johnson has repeatedly
committed himself to making sure that he
can have as many women as possible in
cabinet positions but
i think for campaigners and for
opposition mps until they start to see
that change happen
they will be quite skeptical about it
now of course the conservative party
has had two female prime ministers the
labour party is lagging behind on that
front there are more women in parliament
now than there have been there are some
changes but we're still talking for
example about legislation
for women being able to take maternity
leave when they are in positions of
power in government
that only recently came up only recently
was solved by emergency legislation
the fact that that needed to happen
shows you that sometimes there is a
blind spot
and the reason for that is because women
are still forging that path at the very
top
of government and right now in this day
and age when issues
like clapham common like sarah everard
like domestic violence and abuse and
women's safety are coming up
for lots of people that just isn't good
enough well kate
also on the program this morning was
labour's shadow domestic minister jess
phillips
and i domestic violence minister sorry i
asked her whether the met commissioner
should go i was coming here to talk
about
what needs to change in this one moment
we have
it seems where the politics and the
views and wind is at our back
as women who have been fighting for
better for generations
and i'm here talking about cressida dick
the reality is is that i wish that i'd
had the heavy hand of the law when i'd
been sexually assaulted
i wish for every woman i've ever worked
with that the heavy hand of the law had
been there for them i wish for the woman
in my constituency this week who was
told no further action
on the rape that she'd brought forward i
wish the heavy hand of the police had
been there
for her but the reality is is if crested
dick stays or goes doesn't make women in
this country
more safe and that's what i want to talk
about we need to come together
to take action we don't need to just be
angry we need
action and the minister should be able
to lay out to us
exactly what they're going to do
and kate she she is angry and it's a
subject that she's spoken passionately
about
you know on sky and in the house
repeatedly over time and you know do you
think
she's is she right to sort of suggest
that actually the media focusing
its attention on crested dick and
whether she should stay or go
slightly obfuscating the main problem
well look i think it was reflected
repeatedly actually in the programme
today that while calling for cressida
dick to go
is what some people what some people
have taken away from what happened
yesterday and there certainly is a
an issue i think with the way clapping
common was policed
that's not going to solve this much
broader problem and there are two things
really going on here there are big
questions about
the met and policing in general and
consent and the way that policing
happens and
you know that's become much more of an
issue as we've gone on through this
pandemic and there are really big
questions when we step back
and think about legislation and
accountability because of course
parliament hasn't been operating in the
way that it ordinarily would
because of covert 19 you know there
haven't been as many mps allowed in the
chamber there have been some real
big questions actually about the way
that some of the coronavirus legislation
has been introduced to the house of
commons about the way it's been extended
and actually there's been some questions
too about policing and about the way
that the pandemic has been police so
that's kind of one part of this issue
that i think
is fueling a lot of questions about
cressida dick and the way that she is
doing her job
but of course that's that's secondary
really in this conversation
to the much broader question about
women's safety and i think
for those women they want to see this
conversation
continue they don't want to see this
just become an issue for a week where we
do you know a couple of special programs
they want to see
big systemic change and for that to
happen it requires pressure on
government
it requires people saying look something
needs to happen here and it can't just
be
knee-jerk policy-making it has to be
long-term change and that's why there
are lots of
you know not just women women and men
campaigners opposition party leaders
conservative mps saying okay we need to
take a step back now
and we need to think about how we
approach this properly and part of what
jess was saying to you earlier again
what about education and about health
and about how
this actually this this issue of women's
safety it's not just a women's issue
it's very much a men's issue and it's
very much about having a conversation
about culture
and the way that we approach each other
and the way that we approach society
and that's difficult and it can't happen
instantly and you can't turn around
tomorrow and say oh look we've done this
and now it's all fine it's changed there
have been shifts over time there have
been some positive
moves but of course people want to see
change happen much more quickly
but it will take time it will take a
huge commitment from government to do
that but it will also run alongside this
bigger question about trust in policing
trust in government
and trust in the way that those things
have maybe shifted because of the
pandemic
thanks very much for now kate you're
watching sophie ridge on sunday with me
jane secker
after the break we'll take a look back
at my interview the victims commissioner
dame vera bird who took
a pretty dim view on the police action
last night
this is good technology which has been
around for a few years but hasn't been
very widely used
and what we'd like to do is to roll it
out much faster we're planning to
test 11 000 people over the next year or
so across england
to see whether they have the early signs
of bowel cancer or to give them the all
clear
and obviously the nhs has been under
huge pressure during the pandemic
we've got lists of people waiting for
colonoscopies we diagnose more than 100
people a day
with bowel cancer and we have to test
many times that with a colonoscopy
usually
so this is one way to help take some of
the pressure off those waiting lists
at the same time as bringing in a
technology which is potentially much
more convenient for patients of course
they come through in a few days you have
to analyze the images that come off the
recorder that people wear when they take
the pill
but then they come through very quickly
indeed we have we have people trained to
read
the images that come from the capsule
they produce a report and those then
go back to the patient very quickly so
it's a it's a very
straightforward way of looking for
things like polyps in the bowel or early
cancers
and of course that's what we want is to
be able to catch cancer at an early
stage when it's most curable
um it's really just for cancers in the
bowel
it will of course examine the other
parts of the intestine as it passes
through and in fact i had a patient come
to me the other day
who'd had one of these capsules who had
a tumor in their small intestine which
is
which is much less common but generally
speaking the main thing we're using it
for is to look for bowel cancer
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a forgotten front line they are
dying here
boy we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
i can't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
i'm siobhan robbins sky's southeast asia
correspondent in bangkok
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
hello welcome back to sophie ridge the
take this morning
with me jane secker well also on the
show this morning was the victims
commissioner dame vera beard i was keen
to get her view on the events last night
in clapham common the
organizers tried to cancel the clapham
common one
they failed completely because obviously
emotions are
pouring over the top
and and when it happens you know with
what looked like you were there i i
wasn't but it looked like thousands of
people
you know there is no real prospect of
intervening
in it successfully this quasi-military
thing
of circling around the bandstand where
everybody's just
paid good money out of their wages to
put a bunch of flowers down and express
their view
have you knew some large clawed feet on
it to push
people away it seems to me to be a
dreadful
piece of misjudgment are they really
improving
their chances of kovid not spreading by
putting their knees in the middle of the
back of young women
and putting their hands in handcuffs
it didn't seem to me to be the right
thing to do
and uh kate um she didn't think it was
the right thing to do
she used the phrase quasi military there
didn't she
um but she also talked about the rallies
back in the 1970s the original reclaimed
the night marches and how
in her view things appear to have got
worse for women in society
yeah and isn't that a damning verdict a
damning indictment
i think what we're seeing now is women
taking clearly to the streets again
because they feel that
not enough change has happened and you
know we've talked about how long it
takes for things to feel different
but you know there was another guest in
your program today who said
if women's views and women's action
could change the way this happens then
things would have changed a long time
ago perhaps that's the
wrong way of looking at it if you like
that this isn't a women's issue it's not
an issue for women to go out and march
although of course
you know women will do that they feel
the need to do that to organize and to
make a change but actually it's much
more about
men and including everybody in this
conversation you know we can't exclude
people
you know i don't know i don't know about
you jane but over the course of the last
couple of days
you know i've spoken to lots of men men
who i have huge respect for who are
in my life who had absolutely no idea
that it was fairly standard for women
for me
i'm sure that you do the same thing you
know to run down an alley if it's late
at night to constantly look behind you
as we've had loads of women today to
have your keys between your fingers
they really didn't genuinely understand
the depth of feeling and the fear
and the concern that every single woman
goes through
pretty much every single day of life and
actually if what this has done
is jolt people into that realization
that understanding that this is a
fundamental problem in society that
won't be solved quickly but does need
addressing
then that will be a positive change it
will be something good to take away from
something so incredibly tragic
but it will take continued pressure and
campaigners know it will also take
policy change and that's something that
the government is going to have to grasp
and grapple with and that's why i say
what boris johnson's reaction to this is
is going to be very important kate kate
mccann
kate mccann thank you so much for
joining us this morning
on sophie ridge the take that is all
from me this week sophie is going to be
back next
sunday i hope she's having a lovely
mother's day and stay with us
though now and we will have more on that
criticism of the police's handling
of that vigil in south london last night
the met commissioner
continuing to come under fire to leave